AGAINST THEIR SELF-INTEREST, NOT
THESE RICH PEOPLE.
BERNIE, THANK YOU, GREAT TO SEE
YOU AS ALWAYS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HERALDED THE
JOBS NUMBERS IN THE ROSE GARDEN
TODAY, THE MEDIA GAVE HIM SUCH A
PERPETUAL SMEAR JOB WE FELT IT
WAS OUR DUTY TO CALL IT OUT.
AT THE POINT WERE SUMMARIZED BY
"BLOOMBERG NEWS" REPORTER, WHO
SAID TRUMP SAID HE HOPES GEORGE
FLOYD IS LOOKING DOWN FROM
HEAVEN AND HAPPY ABOUT THE
STRONG JOBS NUMBERS.
WELL, THAT IS A LIE, AND THAT
LIFE SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE AMONG
MORE PROMINENT MEMBERS, LIKE
CNN’S JAKE TAPPER, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PETER
BAKER.
IT EVEN MADE ITS WAY ONTO THE
AIRWAVES, MSNBC, MICHAEL STEELE,
FORMER RNC CHAIR, THAT’S
EMBARRASSING, CALLED TRUMP’S
COMMENTS BORDERLINE BLASPHEMOUS.
NOW, IF THE PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
SAID WITH THOSE MEDIA MEMBERS
WERE ALLEGING, THEN HIS COMMENTS
WOULD BE OUT OF PLACE AND I
WOULD CALL THEM OUT.
BUT SINCE WE WON’T LIE TO YOU,
HERE IS WHAT TRUMP SAID IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
>> EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW
MUST MEAN THAT EVERY AMERICAN
RECEIVES EQUAL TREATMENT IN
EVERY ENCOUNTER WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT, REGARDLESS OF
RACE, COLOR, GENDER, OR CREED,
THEY HAVE TO RECEIVE FAIR
TREATMENT FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY HAVE TO RECEIVE IT.
WE ALL SAW WHAT HAPPENED LAST
WEEK.
WE CAN’T LET THAT HAPPEN.
HOPEFULLY GEORGE IS LOOKING DOWN
RIGHT NOW AND SAYING IT’S A
GREAT THING THAT’S HAPPENING FOR
OUR COUNTRY, THERE IS A GREAT
DAY FOR HIM, IT’S A GREAT DAY
FOR EVERYBODY.
IT WAS A GREAT DAY FOR
EVERYBODY.
IT IS A GREAT, GREAT DAY IN
TERMS OF EQUALITY.
IT’S REALLY WHAT OUR
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES, AND IT’S
WHAT OUR COUNTRY IS ALL ABOUT.
>> Laura: HE’S TALKING ABOUT
EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW,
REGARDLESS OF RACE.
JOINING ME NOW, CHARLIE HURT,
"WASHINGTON TIMES" PUT EDITOR,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
CHARLIE, DID YOU HEAR THE JOBS
REPORT MENTIONED IN THERE?
HOW DO THE MEDIA FIGURES WHO I
CALLED OUT JUSTIFY THE BLATANT
DISHONESTY IN WHAT THEY DID?
I MAD ABOUT THIS.
PICO YOU KNOW, IT’S NOT EVEN
A DISTORTION OF WHAT HE SAID,
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALWAYS
DISTORTING WHAT HE SAID.
THIS IS A FLAT OUT LIE.
THEY ARE MAKING UP SOMETHING
THAT HE SIMPLY DID NOT SAY.
IF YOU LISTEN TO HIS ACTUAL
WORDS, HE’S GIVING A SHOUT OUT,
HE’S APPLAUDING THE PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS WHO ARE PROTESTING
THE TREATMENT OF GEORGE FLOYD.
THAT IS ENTIRELY DIFFERENT,
100%, COMPLETELY, FACTUALLY
DIFFERENT, FROM WHAT PEOPLE ARE
CLAIMING HE SAID.
BUT IF YOU STOP AND THINK ABOUT
IT, AND YOU GO BACK TO THE
BEGINNING OF JUST THIS YEAR,
THIS GUY HAS BEEN THROUGH AN
IMPEACHMENT, WHICH WAS ENTIRELY
MADE UP OF LIES, AND THAT ALL OF
THE STUFF BEFORE THE IMPEACHMENT
WAS MADE UP OF LIES BURIED IN
THE GUY’S BEEN PANDEMIC.
HE’S BEEN GOING THROUGH RIOTS
RIGHT NOW.
THE GOOD NEWS -- THE GOOD
ECONOMIC -- THE STUNNINGLY GOOD
ECONOMIC NEWS THAT CAME OUT
TODAY, I THINK HAS A LOT OF
THESE PEOPLE IN VAPORS.
I THINK THAT THEY HAVE GOT
NOTHING LEFT TO DO BUT TO MAKE
UP THINGS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP,
AND BETWEEN NOW AND THE
ELECTION, LAURA, WE ARE GOING TO
BE LISTENING TO EXACTLY THIS
SORT OF THING, WHERE THESE GUYS
COME UNHINGED AND MAKE STUFF UP
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Laura: I MEAN, CHARLIE,
THEY THOUGHT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WAS GOING TO SAVE
THEM, THEN THEY THOUGHT
IMPEACHMENT WAS GOING TO SAVE
THEM.
BEN MAY THOUGHT THE VIRUS WAS
GOING TO SAVE THEM.
NOW THEY THINK THE PROTEST AND
RIOTS ARE GOING TO SAVE THEM,
AND WAIT A SECOND, THIS GUY IS
REALLY RESILIENT, AND I THINK
THEY ARE FREAKING OUT ABOUT IT.
I THINK THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
FREAKING OUT, AND IT’S GOING TO
GET WORSE.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU.
NOW, THE MEDIA’S ALLIES, THEY
HAVE REAL POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES
CONSEQUENCES.
HERE WAS BIDEN.
>> TOWARDS THE END OF HIS
REMARKS, THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID HE HOPES "GEORGE FLOYD IS
LOOKING DOWN AND SEEING THIS AS
GREAT DAY FOR OUR COUNTRY."
FOR THE PRESIDENT OR TRY TO PUT
ANY OTHER WORDS IN THE MOUTH OF
GEORGE FLOYD, I FRANKLY, THINK
IS DESPICABLE.
>> Laura: CHARLIE, YOUR
REACTION?
>> YOU KNOW, WITH THE MEDIA LIKE
THIS, YOU KIND OF WONDER, WELL,
WHAT ELSE DO YOU EXPECT?
WHAT YOU SAID IN YOUR "ANGLE"
WAS EXACTLY RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
ALL OF THESE PREDICTIONS -- IT’S
NOT ALWAYS LIES AFTER THE FACT,
IT’S ALL OF THE PROGNOSTICATING
BEFORE THE FACT, FROM RUSSIA TO
IMPEACHMENT TO THE PANDEMIC TO
ALL OF IT, THE PREDICTIONS HAVE
BEEN THE MOST DIRE PREDICTIONS.
THEY ARE FEVER DREAMS.
THEY ARE DREAMS ABOUT
ANYTHING -- AND ULTIMATELY WHAT
IT IS IS IT’S ROOTING FOR
FAILURE.
THEY NOT ONLY WANT DONALD TRUMP
TO FAIL, THEY WANT AMERICA TO
FAIL.
THEY WOULD DO ANYTHING -- THEY
WILL CRASH ANY ECONOMY.
THEY WANT THE CITY -- THE
COUNTRY TO BRING TO THE GROUND.
>> Laura: BURN IT ALL DOWN.
>> YEAH, JUST TO BLAME
DONALD TRUMP.
AND SO, NOW THAT ALL OF THESE
THINGS COME ALL OF THEIR
PREDICTIONS AREN’T COMING TO
FRUITION, THEY ARE LEFT WITH
NOTHING ELSE BUT JUST TO LIE
AFTER-THE-FACT, AND THEY ARE
GOING TO KEEP DOING IT, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT?
AMERICAN VOTERS ARE VERY, VERY
CAGEY AND THEY ARE VERY SMART.
EVEN PEOPLE THAT DON’T GET PAID
LIKE YOU AND I DO TO PAY
ATTENTION TO ALL OF THIS, ALL
THE TIME, WE, YOU KNOW, LIVE IT
DAY-TO-DAY.
THEY CAN TELL WHEN PEOPLE ARE
LYING.
AND I DON’T THINK IT IS GOING TO
WORK IN THE SELECTION.
>> Laura: YEP, IT IS NEVER
SEEMLY TO BE ROOTING AGAINST HER
OWN COUNTRY, OR YOUR OWN
COUNTRY’S DEMISE.
WE SEE THAT IN A LOT OF
PROTESTERS, THE ACTIVISTS, THE
VIOLENCE, THE VIOLENCE, AND IT’S
NOT GOOD.
THERE ARE GOOD PROTESTERS AND A